dive deep into the world of finance and
economics with this comprehensive video
course whether you want to make smarter
investment decisions or you're looking
to grasp the intricacies of global
economies this course lays a great
Foundation the course combines Theory
with practical insights Paving the way
for you to navigate the financial realm
with confidence sriram originally taught
this course in person and now is put
together an excellent video course on
these important topics
hello everyone my name is Shram chandi
and I'll be taking you through this
course on economics and finance and how
they're relevant for businesses
throughout this course we'll be learning
a variety of topics starting with the
key concepts for business Capital
markets valuation of stocks business
strategies and financial statements how
to analyze these financial statements
and things like Capital budgeting and
cash flow
we'll also discuss things at the
business cycle and Industry analysis ESG
macroeconomics portfolio diversification
and alternative investment types
throughout this course you'll learn a
variety of different topics in all three
of these disciplines and understand the
interconnected nature of Mac economics
finance and business in this world I
also have a YouTube channel called
change makers media which you can see in
the comments I would greatly appreciate
it if you guys could subscribe there I
share stories on how teens are making an
impact in the world and how you can go
ahead and support them
welcome to the first class on economics
and finance
so a thought experiment to start imagine
you had a magic box and it outputs a
dollar a day or five dollars or twenty
dollars how much ever you want and it
runs forever how much would you pay for
this box
some people say a million dollars some
people say a billion well let's look at
it from a statistical standpoint
instead of a box let's imagine we have a
savings account and it gives you 1.05
interest annually how much would you
have to put into the savings account to
generate a dollar a day
while using Excel we can identify that
the principal or the original amount
we'd have to invest is thirty four
thousand dollars 761.
this is a large amount and fairly so
this is due to the small interest rate
that we're getting on in our savings
account
let's look at another example imagine
you want to buy a house and the market
price is a hundred thousand dollars
you contribute twenty thousand dollars
towards this down payment and take out
an eighty thousand dollar mortgage which
is a loan
how much would you have to pay to get
rid of the mortgage
well if you have an annual contribution
of nine thousand three hundred ninety
six dollars you would assume it would
take just about eight or nine years to
pay off a mortgage but in reality it
takes 20 years and this is due to the
interest rate of ten percent applied on
this mortgage
if you look towards the bottom over the
course of our Pavements you notice that
from 2019 to 2020 our ballots or the
principal only drops by 1 400-ish
dollars this is because the majority of
our nine thousand dollar contribution is
going towards paying off interest on the
mortgage and we see this effect
persisting throughout the course of our
payments however it does diminish as the
size of the principal decreases and our
interest payments decrease
so our key concepts for today's class
return on investment and time value of
money and Net Present Value
so would you rather make in a return of
one thousand dollars or twenty five
percent on an investment
you can't really compare
the apples and towards
so what is ROI ROI is a tool that allows
you to compare the efficiency of one
investment to another investment thus
allows you to compare apples and oranges
Roi measures the amount of return and
investment generates relative to the
amount that you invested
so this is the formula for paternal and
investment current value and investment
minus the cost divided by the cost
so let's see the example of the house
again
imagine you purchased it for a hundred
thousand dollars up front and now the
market value of the house is a hundred
fifty thousand dollars using the ROI
formula we can deduce that you had a
fifty percent return on investment
so why is Roi important because it
allows you to compare assets of
different classes and express it as a
percentage it also provides a basic
measure that's Universal to compare an
investment's profitability as a basic
element in all analysis and decisions
for companies and individuals
but it is limited so let's look at this
example an investment one you invest one
thousand dollars and some real estate
and sell it for one thousand two hundred
dollars a year later
so your Roi is twenty percent
in investment two you bought two
thousand dollars of stock and sold it
for two thousand eight hundred dollars
three years later using the formula you
have a forty percent ROI so according to
Roi the second investment is better but
when you look at the time considerations
you spend three times as much time to
make that forty percent ROI as you did
to the twenty percent ROI hence Roi is
not the say all be all measure of the
value of an investment
okay now let's look at the time value of
money
continuous compounding so let's assume
you have a savings account and
itinerates 10 interest per year over 20
years initially you invest one dollar
into this account
over the course of 20 years with that 10
interest rate the value of your
accountable rise to 6.73
that's 6.73 times the amount you
initially invested and this is the power
of continuous compounding or compound
interest
so time value of money this concept says
that money is worth more today than in
the future because of the potential
earning capacity that money has as seen
in the example and because the power of
money decreases due to macroeconomic
effects such as inflation
so would you prefer one dollar today or
one dollar in five years time
with our previous example we could
reduce that we would like one dollar
today this is because we have the
potential to have flows that money can
create during the Spy period as well as
the avoiding of the potential effects of
inflation
now we have Net Present Value the last
of our three key concepts for this
section of the video
so Net Present Value is a pretty
straightforward concept and as the name
suggests the net of all cash inflows and
cash outflows to determine the value of
an asset cash inflows and cash outflows
essentially represent the income and the
sunken costs that an investment has
taken
so how do we calculate the net present
value
but before we can calculate it we need
to understand Net Present Value is an
important tool to determine the value of
an investment if Net Present Value is
greater than zero that means an
investment was a positive investment
generating good returns
before we can calculate what Net Present
Value is we have to understand something
called the discount rate discount rate
is the interest rate used to to
determine the present value of future
cash flows in a discounted cash flow
analysis
essentially it's the interest rate that
the Federal Reserve charges on
short-term loans we use it to calculate
the value of money in the future due to
macroeconomic policies like inflation
which decrease the value of future cash
flows so once we understand what the
discount rate is we can accurately
calculate the net present value
so let's assume you purchased a vending
machine to purchase the vending machine
you had to spend ten thousand dollars
this is reflected in year zero with a
minus ten thousand dollar cash flow
which is a negative cost in year one
your vending machine refers you two
thousand dollars in profits and in
subsequent years it returns three
thousand five thousand and seven
thousand dollars
so if you were to add up these numbers
it would give you a seven thousand
dollar Net Present Value however
accounting for the discount rate which
assumes the loss of money due to uh
increasing interest rates our Net
Present Value is only four thousand
seven hundred and four dollars although
it's less than the seven thousand
dollars that we would have received if
money didn't lose value it's still
greater than zero which indicates that
the vending machine is indeed a good
investment
okay so here we have a Google Sheets
laid out with the payments of a mortgage
you would make if you were to buy a
house
so referring to a similar example let's
imagine we're buying a house for a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars this
time
so you have a twenty percent down
payment which is thirty thousand dollars
which leaves you with a payment of a
hundred twenty thousand dollars which
you're going to be paying off with a
loan so let's say your loan principal is
120 000 you have a yearly interest rate
of ten percent this means your yearly
payment for a 20-year mortgage would
come out to thirteen thousand eight
hundred and ninety six dollars so as you
can see here over these 20 years you're
going to be paying off this mortgage
with your yearly payments so the first
every year you pay off the exact same
amount however the principal amount
decreases so in the first year you start
with 120 000.
uh after your first payment you're left
with 118 000 and so on so forth until
you eventually reach zero at the end of
your 20-year mortgage period
however it's important to note the
changes to the principal amount as time
progresses
if you notice from year zero to year one
our principal only decreased by just shy
of two thousand dollars even though
you're making a payment for almost
fourteen thousand dollars the reason for
this is the majority of your payment is
going towards paying off the yearly
interest rate on your principal which is
ten percent of a hundred twenty thousand
dollars which is twelve thousand dollars
so of your thirteen thousand eight
hundred ninety six dollars twelve
thousand is going towards the interest
and only one thousand eight hundred
ninety six is going towards paying off
your principal
this goes to show you how interest rates
uh can actually end up costing you a lot
of money so 120 000 loan ends up costing
two hundred and seventy seven thousand
nine hundred four dollars by the end to
pay off the principal and the interest
so that means you're paying a hundred
and fifty seven thousand dollars 940 on
interest
all right so what are capital and
financial markets what is Capital
Finance and who provides it and how do
businesses and governments obtain
Financial Capital through these markets
so the financial Market is a place where
two or more people come together to
exchange goods or services they can be
physical places like a grocery store or
Supermarket or virtual places like for
example the Netflix subscription page
although this is less obvious of a
Marketplace it is still an area where
two parties the individual purchasing
the subscription and Netflix come
together to exchange goods and services
or in this example a Netflix
subscription which is a service
so the importance of financial markets
financial markets are vital for growth
of firms as well as achieving individual
consumers as desires many firms produce
goods and services that individuals
would not be able to acquire themselves
as a result it's important for financial
markets to exist so consumers can have
access to these Goods it's also
important for firms this is because
unless they're able to trade their goods
and services they won't be able to make
Returns on what they're producing and
grow as a result
so now we'll go over the stock and bond
markets
so first of all what is a stock
so a stock is a security that represents
a portion of ownership in a company
so people can only purchase stocks from
a public or private type of company
public companies are companies that
trade their stock on a public platform
or anybody can purchase it examples are
Amazon apple and Tesla if you wanted to
right now you can go and purchase their
stock
private companies on the other hand are
held by certain owners typically the
people who started the company in
certain situations they may choose to
sell their stock but not on a public
platform only privately to maybe their
friends and family
so the what are stocks issued stocks are
issued by companies to raise finances
for their goals these may be expansion
raising money for inventory and so on
stocks are also referred to as equity
and as many of you have seen in the
Shark Tank show we see the term Equity
thrown around in this example Kevin
offers four hundred thousand dollars for
an 8.2 million dollar valuation so the
company's total Equity or stock is worth
8.2 million dollars and Kevin's offering
four hundred thousand dollars which
represents 4.8 percent of that total
Equity so he would be owing 4.85 of the
total stock of that company
so now what is a bond a bond is an
instrument that represents a loan made
by an investor which is you and a
borrower so bonds can be issued by a
variety of places unlike stocks which
are only issued by firms bonds can be
issued by firms governments States and
other government-affiliated
organizations
bonds have four main features
their issue price which is what you buy
it for the face value which includes the
price you're buying it for as well as
the interest payments the coupon rate or
the interest rate which is the set of
payments you'll be receiving over the
course of the bond the coupon date which
is when these payments will be made to
you and the maturity date which is when
the lifetime of the bond is expended and
the issue price is returned to you
so bonds are used typically to fund
projects for these organizations
they only last for a certain period of
time as determined by the maturity rate
when the bond is issued and they either
have fixed or variable payments
something interesting about bonds is
that they're inversely related to
interest rates in the market this is
because as interest rates rise the lower
coupon rate of the bonds become less
desirable as a result Bond issuers lower
their price
an example of a government-funded
project could be developing
infrastructure such as buildings schools
Paving roads and so on if the government
doesn't already have enough funds to do
this project they may issue bonds to
race capital and pursue these projects
so the differences between stocks and
bonds so typically stocks are more risky
this is due to the volatility of the
stock market resulting in companies
values appreciating and appreciating
additionally stocks are only issued by
firms or companies
stocks also give you ownership over a
company and you get paid in the form of
dividends and appreciation in the value
of the company
Dividends are when companies may choose
to offer you some money that they make
from their profits and appreciation is
when the total value of the company
Rises as a result when you purchase a
sock for say for example when the
company stock is worth a hundred dollars
and it appreciates to 120 you make money
off of that 20 appreciation
additionally stocks give you ownership
over a company and in some situations
will give you decision making power
so now bonds bonds are seen as less
risky because they have fixed payments
which are determined when the bond is
purchased and they they give you a
maturity once they mature you get your
initial payment back
bonds are issued also by firms and
governments along with other
organizations
bonds are in the form of debt not
ownership so when you purchase a bond
the person that you purchase the bond
from will be making you payments
furthermore bonds don't give you any
decision-making power since they're only
debt and not ownership
we can see the risk between bonds and
stocks in this example
so here these stocks are represented by
the dark blue line whereas the bonds are
represented by the light purple
the stock prices are very volatile as
they're swinging up and down cyclically
almost whereas bonds are on a steady
much lesser volatile growth rate this
represents how stocks are much more
volatile and when at certain dates if
you choose to sell a stock you may make
a negative return whereas if you choose
well bonds you can't sell but once your
bond reaches a maturity you're almost
guaranteed to make profits unless the
company or organization that you
purchase the bond from defaults or goes
bankrupt
so how do we value stocks on any asset
in general well there's two main factors
that we have to include when it when
trying to value a stock or Bond or any
asset for that matter
the expected cash flows and the risk
associated with the value as we
discussed earlier cash flows are the
total revenues we'll be making along
with the sunken costs of purchasing an
asset
and risk risk can be represented with
the chance for financial losses or the
chance that a company even goes bankrupt
and you lose your value
okay so stock valuation there is a lot
of uncertainty when valuing a stock and
part of this is due to the fact that
there's so many different ways to value
a stock
for example there's a discounted cash
flow method which we'll be looking into
next there's the constant growth divided
by dividend discount method and there's
also techniques called comparables which
we'll also be discussing such as price
to earnings price to books and prices
sales as a result there's no standard
convention to measure a stock and when
people are comparing stocks it's best to
use the most information you have
available to you and try and do all
these techniques which is of course
unviable in the real world though
so the discounted cash flow method
discounted cash flow method is similar
to what we discussed in the previous
section where we take all the expected
cash flows for an asset from including
the sunken costs and the revenues that
it would like to generate in the future
and discount these values meaning we
adjust these the value of money in
accordance with uh macroeconomic
features like inflation and so on to
ensure that the future value of money is
converted to the present value of money
so what are the pros of this technique
theoretically this is the most sound
method if the analyst is confident in
their assumptions and forecasts
additionally it's not significantly
influenced by temporary market
conditions or non-economic factors like
if the industry is suffering from a
temporary lack of resources this
technique ensures that those factors are
overcome when calculating the value
and this is especially useful when there
when this Com when a company you're
valuing is in an industry where there's
no other competitors or very limited
competitors so that way there's limited
or no comparable information as a result
you only base your forecast off the
individual company
the cons of this technique are that it
can vary over a wide range of values
because the predictions are based on
forecasts which are likely to be
inaccurate additionally it's very time
intensive compared to the other
evaluation techniques which we'll
discuss later
and additionally forecasting future
performance is very difficult since it
requires lots of statistical tools and
again it is likely to be inaccurate or
imprecise
so evaluation Frameworks we'll be
looking at comps now so what are comps
comps are also called comparables or
multiples and it is a valuation
technique that is based on comparing
companies within an industry it involves
using metrics such as price to earnings
price to books and other relevant ratios
to that of similar companies in the same
industry
the rationale behind using comps lies in
the principle that companies within the
same industry tend to have similar
financial and operational
characteristics due to Shared market and
economic factors
by evaluating the valuation of a company
against its peers investors can gain
insights into its performance within the
industry and whether it's over under or
fairly valued
so the two most popular forms of comps
are price to earnings ratio and
something called Enterprise Value to
edicta or ebitda
so these are examples of certain types
of comps we have price earnings price to
sales Enterprise Value to earning before
interest tax and depreciation price to
cash flow and price to earnings the
reason these are better than discounting
cash flow in terms of time is that their
ratios so they can be calculated very
quickly all you have to do is go to the
financial documents of a company look at
their numbers that they're reporting and
calculating them which allows for Swift
and easy comparison between companies
within the same industry
all right in this section we'll be going
over business strategy any of the
financial documents related to it so
first what is business strategy well
it's a plan of action or a policy
designed to achieve the major or overall
aim of a company so at the time to
develop a coherent economic strategy and
the plans to ensure the future success
of the company in both its goals and
financial success
so one key aspect of the business
strategy is the mission statement the
mission statement is the summary of the
aims and the values of a company the key
elements of a mission statement are the
purpose the target audience and
explanation of the business how the
business is unique and the values that
the business has and it has to do all of
these things in just a couple sentences
so let's look at a couple examples here
we have Microsoft and their business
statement is to empower every person in
every organization on the planet to
achieve more
we have Honda maintaining a global
Viewpoint we are dedicated to supplying
products of the highest quality yet at a
reasonable price for worldwide customer
satisfaction
and Walmart to save people money so that
they can live better
across these three statements there's
common features one they're short two
they're easy to remember and three they
showcase the core values and missions of
these companies
okay so the next part about a company
analysis there's various tools that
companies include to create their
business statement and one of these
principal tools is a SWOT analysis A
SWOT analysis helps the company position
themselves and understand where they are
in the marketplace against their
competitors
there are four key elements of SWOT
analysis strengths weaknesses
opportunities and threats which thus
produce the name SWAT
so the strengths of a company are its
competitive Advantage the assets that it
had that are proprietary and products
that are performing well
these are the trends because they are
unique features of a company that other
competitions don't have
the weaknesses of a company are things
that they lack that their competitors
have things that their competitors do
better
and any resource limitations that a
company may be experiencing
so strengths and weaknesses are within
the company and its operations then we
have opportunities and threats
uh threats are new legislature which
threatens their company's operations any
new emerging competition and changes to
Consumer attitudes and opinions
opportunities are a technologies that a
company can integrate to improve its
processes emerging press and media which
can help our company generate any
publicity and underserved markets that a
company can integrate themselves into
resident opportunities are not directly
involved in the company and are external
and can be affected the company over
time
so here we have a bit more of a detailed
explanation what strengths and
weaknesses are so strengths are the
internal attributes and resources of a
company that Propel the company towards
success it represents the area where
your organizational outperforms others
evident by both your competitors and
your customers
weaknesses are the facets that hinder
favorable outcomes for your business
they pinpoint areas that require
improvements shedding light on where
your company falls short compared to its
competitors
opportunities Encompass external
elements that can be leveraged to your
advantage these are prevailing market
trends that when capitalized upon using
your strengths can enhance revenue and
provide a Competitive Edge
threats denote external factors that
jeopardize your organization's success
these Encompass advantages held by
competitors to mitigate these risks it's
crucial to employ your strengths
strategically
SWOT analysis when used can help an
accompany understand where it is now in
its industry and what the future holds
and how the company can progress itself
in a beneficial way
one more tool that a business can use to
help it understand the importance of
certain products or Services cells is
the BCG Matrix so the BCG Matrix
otherwise known as the Boston Consulting
Group Matrix is a business analysis tool
that helps organizations assess their
product portfolios performance and
potential
so as you can see on the diagram there
are four different categories Stars cash
cows question marks and dogs and you can
categorize products depending on their
market growth rate and their relative
market share
so Stars these are products with high
market shares that are growing in fact
that are in fast growing markets they
they have the potential to generate
significant profits due to their
position in this industry so if a
company dominates 90 of the market share
for it for it in for a niche that is
growing very fast the product that
they're selling is likely to be a star
cash cows are products that have high
market shares in markets that aren't
growing so fast
they're um while they may not have as
much growth potential they generate
steady cash flow which is often a
desirable for businesses so similar to
stars but they don't have the future
potential and instead they're making
money right now
question marks are products that country
may have low market share in however the
Market's likely to expand in the future
they require consideration as to whether
a company should invest in it to develop
its market share and potentially create
it into a star or to let it go and
become a dog
and dogs are products that have a loan
market share and a market growth in a
market that isn't growing they won't
generate significant profits for the
company and if a company needs to reduce
some of its uh products or services that
it's offering the dogs are the first to
go
the BCG Matrix can help a company
allocate its resources effectively by
suggesting strategies for products or
services that fall into each specific
quadrant
and the last strategic business tool
we'll talk about is Porter's generic
strategies supporters genetic strategies
are a set of strategic approaches
developed by Michael Porter as the name
suggests to help businesses understand
where they stand in the industry and to
help them gain a competitive advantage
so again there are four quadrants in
this industry in this uh diagram there's
cost leadership differentiation cost
focus and differentiation Focus so cost
leadership is a strategy that focuses on
becoming the lowest cost producer in a
in any in an industry this is achieved
by economies of scale efficient
operations and cost controls uh this can
attract a wide consumer customer base
and potentially deter new entrants from
the industry then we have
differentiation differentiation aims to
create a unique or distinctive product
unlike others on the market and this can
be achieved through unique product
design branding or even customer service
by offering something that's valuable
and unique companies can often charge
premium prices and customers will be
willing to pay
and then it's removed the bottom there
are the focus or Niche strategies in the
niche market these strategies often
involve concentrating efforts on a
specific Market or a specific segment
this can be done either through cost
Focus or through differentiation Focus
which means becoming the lowest cost
leader in a niche and offering a
uniquely tailored product in a nation
respectively by focusing on smaller
specialized markets companies can build
stronger relationships with their
customers and it's much easier to
maintain these relationships
by choosing one of these generic
strategies businesses can align their
operations marketing efforts and
resource allocations to create a
sustainable competitive advantage
so now we'll be looking at the three
main financial statements that all
companies need to report or financial
documents rather
so we have the statement of profare loss
the statement of financial position and
the cash flow forecast
it's important to note that these
documents do have different names that
they're referred to as I've indicated
some of the popular other forms in
parenthesis
so if you do go on the internet and you
come across an income statement or Prof
or loss statement please do know that
they're the same thing
so each of these statements has a
different purpose which we'll be
exploring soon and when combined
together they provide an in-depth look
at the through the lens of finances and
performance and how a company is
performing and whether its stock is good
and also keep in mind that all publicly
traded companies need to report these
three documents to ensure transparency
with the public and their investors
whereas private companies don't need to
report this
also note that in these documents any
negative numbers or losses will be
represented with parenthesis around them
or in earlier examples I used the color
red however in financial documents it's
important to know all negative numbers
are in parenthesis
all right
so first we have the statement of profit
or loss
the statement of profit or loss is a
financial statement that summarizes the
revenues costs and expenses of a company
over a period of time
so just to start with all of these
financial documents have this opening
section it'll of course include the
title the company
and what type of financial document it
is and more importantly the period of
time that is coming from so in this
example we have the end of the year at
this whatever year okay
so the statement of profit or loss is
also known as the statement of
operations statement of financial
results or income the earning statement
the expense statement income statement
and so on
it's important to compare this profit
and loss statement over time to see
changes within a company so this example
we only have it for one year but
investors typically look at several
years and compare it on a horizontal
analysis which we'll look at later
to see the growth of a company over time
so whenever we're looking at this
document it's important to start from
the top so we look at the sales revenue
and we as we go we slowly reduce the uh
the total sales revenue until we receive
the retained profit
so starting at cost of sales this
includes the cost of manufacturing goods
and the pro and the cost through which
you would have to sell it this includes
lighting at the store and so on this
leads you to your gross profit then
after expenses you get your profits
before interest and tax after paying
interest you get profits before tax
after paying your taxes you get profit
for your period so this is essentially
all the Surplus that a company has left
over then you pay your dividends to your
shareholders and this leaves the
retained profit for the company
so it's important to note that this is
for a profit making entity even
non-profit making entities do report
these statements however in place of
profit they use the term Surplus since
they aren't well for-profit and then
right
so the statement of financial position
this statement's a bit longer so we'll
look at it in two parts assets and
liabilities but essentially this
statement says at the end of a financial
period where do you as a company stand
so the first half the assets so again
looking from the top we have the name of
the company title of the document and
the peer that is reporting for
so in this section we look at the assets
and assets are split into non-current
and current assets
so non-curred assets are assets that a
company will be holding for a period
greater than a year this includes things
like the factory that is built on any of
the technical equipment they have and so
on
current assets on the other hand are
things that our assets that company will
hold for less than a period of for less
than a period of a year this includes
things like cash debtors and stock
so when you calculate the total value of
your non-current assets you get 800 year
and current assets is a one thousand one
hundred so your total assets add up to
1900.
one thing that you may notice is
accumulated depression depreciation and
it's in parentheses and it's a negative
factor although it's beyond the uh scope
of this course I'll give you a quick
look at what depreciation is it's an
accounting technique used by companies
to reduce their overall assets which can
help them in terms of tax breaks and so
on
but yeah when you add your non-trans
assets and your current assets you get
your total assets of 1900.
now liabilities again liabilities are
split into current liabilities and
non-current liabilities current
liabilities are liabilities that the
company will hold for a period less than
a year and non-current are liabilities
that a company will hold for a period
greater than you
things like Bank overdraft which are
essentially drawing from a bank account
until it gets to a negative point or is
a current liability trade Predators is
when a company is trading with another
company
and the person you're trading with
allows you to pay later essentially like
an IOU
and we also have short-term loans which
we which will be paid back in a period
less than a year and these add up to
your total current liabilities other
non-current liabilities are just
long-term loans which you would take out
from the bank
and these add up to your total
liabilities
your net assets are your total assets
minus your total liabilities so your
total assets are 1900 and your total
liabilities are 800. so 1900 minus 800
gives you 1 100 which is your net assets
and an important calculation to know to
see if you've done this the financial
position correct is to take your assets
and equate them to liabilities plus
shareholder Equity if this comes out
equal then you get it right
shareholder Equity essentially the sheer
Capital that your the value of your
shares and the retained earnings of a
company for the period
so yeah that's your statement of
financial position
and now we have the cash flow forecast
the cash flow forecast is debt is for a
shorter period of time and it talks
about all the money going in and out of
a company for in this case three months
so yeah it allows advisors to assess the
individual inflows and outflows of a
company to determine how important
certain things in the company are and
how expensive they are and how they can
be cut down to improve the total net
cash flow of a company
it also allows the company uh it also
allows for a month by month comparison
to see the growing effects of the
company's operations
so as you see here in January the
opening balance is 800 however the total
cash outflows which are 306 are greater
than the inflows which are 300 and as a
result the closing balance decreases by
six
million so you have a closing balance of
2 million and we see this negative cash
flow uh going over a period of three
months which allows us to see that
operating at this state for this company
has negative effects and that suggests
that some outflows need to be decreased
or inflows need to be increased
otherwise companies may need to take out
other for um incorporate other forms of
finances
so the importance of these forms these
reforms as I stated earlier need to be
made public for publicly traded
companies it's important that companies
ensure uh transparency with their
investors and with the public so that
investors can make informed decisions
whether they should invest in the
company
these are all these documents are also
important for people within the company
to ensure that uh to create calculations
like return on it Equity or Roe and you
can only do that by comparing across
these documents or cross-referencing
so yeah
even now you can search up a certain
publicly traded company and find these
financial documents on the internet
however you won't be able to do so with
private companies
so now we'll be looking at how to
analyze this financial statements that
we've just discussed
so there's three techniques that we can
use you can use ratios a horizontal
analysis and a common size technique so
first we'll go over ratios which are in
my opinion the simplest way and the
quickest way to analyze
so there's four types of ratios
profitability ratios which measure your
return on investment your liquidity
ratios which measure how easily you can
move your money around activity ratios
which are representation of your
day-to-day operations and leverage
ratios which represent how well you can
utilize debt
so we have profitability ratios
profitability ratios are Financial
indicators used to evaluate a company's
ability to generate profits relative to
its Revenue assets and equity
key profitability ratios include the
gross profit margin as you can see on
screen which measures profit after
deducting production costs or cost of
goods sold and the net profit margin
which assesses overall profit after all
expenses
we also have return on assets and return
on equity which are common ratios that
show how efficiently a company generates
profits from its assets and shareholder
Equity respectively
these ratios help investors in stock
stakeholders gauge a company's
profitability and its Effectiveness in
turning Revenue into earnings so as you
can see I have the formulas for each of
these profitability ratios listed on
screen and the major at all this
information can obviously be found from
the three financial documents
next we have liquidity ratios liquidity
ratios are Financial metrics that assess
the company's ability to meet its
short-term Financial Obligations they
measure the abilities the firm's ability
to convert assets Into Cash quickly to
recover or cover immediate liabilities
common liquidity ratios include the
current ratio which divides the current
assets by current liabilities and the
quick ratio which excludes less liquid
assets like inventory
these ratios provide insights into a
company's Financial Health and its
capacity to handle unexpected expenses
or downturns high liquidity ratios
generally indicate better short-term
Financial stability and flexibility
however they aren't in the ultimate
analysis technique for liquidity
activity ratios um so activity ratios
are also known as asset utilization
ratios and they analyze how efficiently
a company manages to use its assets to
generate Revenue they provide insights
into how well a company utilizes its
resources and operations for example we
have inventory turnover which measures
how quickly inventory is sold and
replenished and things like average
collection period
activity ratios help businesses optimize
their operations manage working capital
and identify areas where improvements
can lead to increased productivity and
profitability
finally we have debt leverage ratios
debt ratios are Financial metrics that
evaluate a company's level of debt in
relation to its Equity or assets these
ratios offer insights into a company's
financial leverage and risk
common debt ratios include the debt to
asset ratio which measures debt relative
to the total assets a company has
this ratio helps assess the company's
ability to handle its debt obligations
and also provides valuable information
for investors and creditors regarding
the firm's Financial stability and
transfer risk
all right so there's nuances to these
ratios although these ratios are super
simple and easy to calculate they aren't
that useful when you're comparing firms
across Industries so for example we have
Walmart and Honda if we take the example
of the liquidity ratio uh liquidity
ratios with the quick ratio you can't
compare Honda and Walmart it's likely
that one of the companies will have very
different styles of inventory and the
ways they process their equipment is
very different however it these ratios
are useful when you're comparing
companies within the same industry in
the same position
all right so now we can go through a
quick simplified version to of a
Consolidated income statement and all
these financial documents to calculate
two ratios the gross profit margin and
the net profit margin for Tesla so I got
this data from The Wall Street Journal
and it's just a Consolidated income
statement of Tesla with all this
information here so
to calculate the gross profit margin I
have the formula right here so it's the
revenues minus the cost of goods sold
divided by the total revenues so using
Excel we can use the minus function to
take the revenues which is right here
and subtract it from the cost of goods
sold which is right here
and this gives us twenty thousand eight
hundred fifty three and now we can use
the divide function to divide this value
by the total revenues which is the
formula right here
and this gives us the gross profit
margin ratio of 0.255 and so on and now
we can do the same thing with the net
profit margin but this is much more
simple this is just the net income
divided by revenues so we take the
divide function
and we look for the net income
which is right here and you take this
and you divide it by the revenues which
is right here again
I'm using Excel we can calculate it to
be 0.15446
so this is a super simplified example
the information on this Excel sheet is
very basic
in reality when you're calculating some
of the other ratios you're going to need
to wrap cross-reference these financial
documents because lots of the
information is located on the cash flow
forecast some is required reporting the
income statement and so on so as a
result it becomes a lot more complicated
but if you have access to all the files
which you should for publicly traded
companies you'll be able to do these
calculations no problem
the next technique is horizontal
analysis or Trend analysis so horizontal
analysis of financial statements
involves comparing financial ratios and
benchmarks or any item over a number of
accounting periods this method is also
known as Trend analysis so horizontal
analysis allows the assessment of
relative changes in different aspects of
the financial statements to be seen over
time
so let's look at this example
one thing to notice when you're reading
these financial statements over time is
that the most recent years represented
on the leftmost column and the most and
the oldest years on the right most
column which kind of goes against our
left or right reading Style in English
so it's important to keep that in mind
but if we look at the numbers we see a
growth in the sales growth in the cost
of sales a growth and profit and so on
so this can be calculated so the change
the numerical change can be calculated
and listed in this column and the
percentage change can be listed here the
percentage change is calculated by
taking the difference and dividing it by
the overall amount so that's also called
the year over year change
so returning to our Consolidated income
statement for Tesla that we saw in the
previous example we can see the same
changes happening over time so the
leftmost column is the most recent year
which is 2022 and the rightmost column
is 28t so this records data for Tesla
over the course of five years
keep in mind that this some of this data
happened during the covid-19 pandemic
which may have skewed results so that
shows you that it's important to realize
that macroeconomic effects like a
pandemic or other industrial shocks can
affect this data
but in large it's not that big of a
contribution at least a Tesla so if we
look we see a growth in sales revenue so
from 20 to 21
000 24
000 31 000 and then rapid growth from
2020 to 2022 with 20 000 uh growth and
then 30 000 Euros
at the same processes can be seen across
various other factors or various other
items and this goes to show you how this
horizontal statement can be used to
analyze growth over time even with Tesla
the last tool we'll be discussing in
this section is common size analysis
which is a Financial State okay
the last technique we'll be discussing
in this section is common size analysis
common size financial statements show
each line item expressed as a percentage
of a base figure within the statement
and it's used for vertical analysis so a
common size financial statements help to
analyze and compare a company's
performance over several periods the
comments as percentages can subsequently
be used to compare those with
competitors and determine how a company
is performing relative to the rest of
the industry
a common size income statement is an
income statement in which each line item
is expressed as a percentage of the
value of Revenue or sales
a common size balance sheet is a balance
sheet that displays both a numeric value
and relative percentage for total assets
so in the following example we'll be
looking over a common size statement for
an income statement
or balance sheet okay so here we have a
generic example of what one would look
like as you can see we have the normal
side of a balance sheet or Finance
statement of financial position except
one more column is added that expresses
everything as percentages
in this example you would think
percentages aren't too helpful and you'd
be right and that's because the numbers
here are very straightforward the total
assets are a hundred thousand which
makes a hundred percent and all these
numbers are very straightforward however
in a situation where numbers are much
more miscellaneous and intricate these
percentages help to clarify and watch
more information
here this is extremely helpful because
it can show us what percent of our
assets for example our current assets
are at which four so in this example for
our current assets the majority is in
the form of total cash and inventory
whereas the rest is in the form of
prepaid expenses and accounts
receivables
this can suggest that the company may
need to invest its total cash into other
assets that can generate revenue and it
may have an inventory issue turning
inventory into actual Revenue
and if we look at our non-current assets
the majority of our assets are in our
planned property and Equipment whereas
very little is in our Goodwill this can
help us identify what value certain
parts of our business bring and what
parts aren't as helpful so in the
non-current example we see how we have
so much value in our equipment our
property in our plan whereas the brand
name and value which is Goodwill isn't
that strong
this can also help us identify which
parts of our liabilities are the
greatest and which parts are the weakest
and how we can take future steps to
address these and prevent any other
issues from rising
the same thing can be seen for other
forms of shapements like the income
statement which I mentioned earlier but
it's essentially the same thing just in
another financial statement
all right
so let's say you have the opportunity to
install solar panels on your house
the solar panel company says it's going
to cost you ten thousand dollars to
install solar panels
but they say in the long run you're
going to be able to save money
should you make the investment
well in this class we're going to be in
this section we're going to be talking
about capital budget Inc
so what is capital budgeting why do we
do it and how is it done and with these
tools we can answer whether we should
make the investment for the solar panels
so first what is capital budgeting
Capital budgeting is the process of
evaluating and selecting long-term
investment projects like solar panels
that involve significant financial
outlays it's a decision-making processes
for businesses and individuals to
determine which projects are worth
pursuing based on their potential to
generate returns or benefits over an
extended period
Capital budgeting helps organizations
and individuals allocate their Financial
Resources effectively maximizing the
value of Investments and minimizing the
risk of making poor choices it's a
systematic approach that considers not
only the immediate costs and returns but
also the long-term impact on financial
performance and overall strategic goals
of an individual or business
okay so first of all why do companies
even make investments in fixed assets
well Investments can increase capacity
they can overcome some regulations they
are Innovative which can give companies
a unique advantage and there's so many
other reasons
but why is capital budgeting imported
for valuation
Capital budgeting is important for
several reasons but I'll give you three
main reasons first of all it helps the
resource allocation there's limited
financial resources and capital
budgeting can help ensure a company's
focus on the most promising Investments
it also helped for long-term planning
this is because it allows companies to
plan for the future by considering the
effects of their investment using tools
that we'll discuss later over extended
period and manage risk while maximizing
returns and it also considers the time
value of money again which we'll discuss
further but Capital budgeting considers
the time value of money recognizing that
a dollar today is worth more than a
dollar in the future this also ensures
that cash flow predictions are properly
discounted
okay
so how do companies pay for Investments
they pay for it in three ways using cash
flow debt and equity
so before we continue there's two more
Concepts you need to understand before
we're able to discuss Capital budgeting
and how to actually consider it internal
rate of return or irr for short and cost
of capital
the internal rate of return or irr is a
finance term that helps us assess how
lucrative an investment or project could
be irr is the annual growth that an
investment is expected to make if the
irr is higher than what you could earn
from a safe investment like in like a
bank deposit or investing in some safe
stocks then the project might be worth
the risk in short irr helps us decide if
a business idea is a good investment
so the steps of capital budgeting first
a project proposal is developed this
involves either individuals or
businesses looking at an opportunity to
make an investment and thinking it's a
good idea then management reviews and
prioritizes projects based on their
economic viability so after looking at
the potential cash flow projections
management will either decide if an
investment is positive or negative for
the company and thus decide to
prioritize or ignore it then funds are
allocated on these projects to ensure
the development and the results are
tracked to see if the projections are
accurate if projections are inaccurate
they're either funds are either removed
reduced or increased
after the investment is completed
companies can reflect on the process and
re and decide whether future similar
Investments should be made
so Capital cash flows
the value of an ambition initial
investment is equal to the cost of the
new asset plus the installations cost
associated with the new asset minus the
after tax proceeds from selling the old
asset
keep in mind the after tax proceeds from
selling an old asset is equal to the
sale price minus the tax on capital gain
which is a bit Advanced for this course
but all you need to understand is that
that is considered when calculating the
price of the initial investment
so Capital budgeting results in changes
in working capital if a current asset
increases in value it's a use of working
capital if current liabilities increase
it's a source of work in capital
that means current assets are cash so or
in inventory which are uses of a capital
and liabilities are things like invest
and Loans which are sources of working
capital
an increase in networking Capital means
it's a source of cash for the company
and a decrease is a use of cash
so Capital budgeting are the three main
methods that we use to decide whether we
should invest are payback period which
we'll discuss next Net Present Value
which we've discussed earlier and irr
which you've all just discussed
so payback period it's a very basic
concept and it essentially discusses how
long it takes for a company to recoup
its Investments on a fixed asset so in
this example we have a Ford factory
initially it costs five thousand dollars
to invest in the Sport Factory
however as the years go on it generates
positive cash flows
so payback period essentially looks at
how long it takes for the company to
generate to retrieve a net positive cash
flow and as you can see initially the
cash flows the cumulative cash flow is
negative until year four when it finally
breaks positive
okay so now let's return back to our
example our solar panel costs ten
thousand dollars should we make the
investment
so using Capital budgeting techniques we
can predict the cash flows
so the cash flows over the years are two
thousand two thousand five hundred three
thousand five hundred four thousand and
four thousand five hundred with an
initial cost of ten thousand should we
install these panels
well if you look at the cost of capital
which is twelve percent that means any
other investment we could invest in
would generate one thousand two hundred
dollars in Net Present Value
if our investment on these solar panels
is greater than our other cost of
capital then it's a good investment so
using discounting our cash flows we can
find a value we find that the value of
the solar panels the net present value
of the solar panels is 1219 which is
greater than the value of odd which is
greater than our cost of capital
so here we can see how we calculate our
Net Present Value and how it shifts
based on our discount rate and our cash
flows so this Excel function is set up
so that
the discount rate is called percent
which is our cost of capital and our
cash flows are accounted for and you can
do this by typing equals npv just click
on the discount comma and selecting our
cash flows which yields the same number
here and here
so if we wanted to adjust our factors to
see how it would be in different
scenarios we can change these numbers
and see how it would work so if our
discount rate was instead of 12 20 and
you can see how our Net Present Value
has decreased this suggests that other
Investments which have higher which are
better cost of capital could have been a
better investment than investing in
these solar panels however if we
decrease our cost of capital of
something like five percent we see the
Net Present Value increases even greater
this shows how different costs of
capital can affect the net present value
of our investment by comparing
alternative Investments
additionally we can look at how cash
flow affects a Net Present Value if our
initial cost was 20 000 instead of ten
thousand thus essentially meaning the
cost was double our Net Present Value
decreases significantly this shows how
the price of investment can also affect
the value
and that increasing our invest
increasing our cash flows significantly
increases our Net Present Value
all right in this section we'll be
talking about Mac reconautics so first
of all what is macroeconomics
macroeconomics is the branch of
Economics that studies the overall
behavior of an economy focusing on
large-scale factors like economic growth
inflation unemployment and national
income it examines how policies and
events impact the economy as a whole
rather than individuals such and
individual businesses or individual
markets
some of the key factors in
macroeconomics are the size of the
economy economic growth government
policy fiscal policy monetary policy
inflation and international trades most
of these which we'll touch upon
so one thing that we should understand
is the business cycle the business cycle
is very intertwined with economics
everything is cyclical so the business
cycle also known as the economic cycle
is the recurring pattern of fluctuations
and an economy's overall activity over
time it can be divided into four main
free phases as you guys can see in this
diagram
it's so in this example it starts with
the trough or the lowest point
so the trough is the lowest point in the
business cycle
um at this point economic economic
activity is at its lowest and economic
conditions are the worst however at this
point the economy uh sets the stage for
a potential turnaround as it moves into
the expansion stage
features of this stage is monetary and
fiscal policy employed by the central
banks and government which we'll touch
upon later
uh starting to rise in economic growth
an increase in employment and
manufacture manufacturing from this
trough and a gradual shift towards
increases in profits
next we have the expansion phase during
his phase economic activity such as
production employment and consumer
spending is on the rise as said by the
trough businesses are expanding and
there's a general sense of optimism and
an increase in consumer confidence
throughout the economy growth is driven
by an increase in consumer demand
investment and also by monetary and
fiscal policy
as you can see the effects of fiscal and
monetary policy are starting to benefit
however the governments and central
banks are drawing back on their
intervention
economic growth is also still positive
however it's not as rapid as it was
during the trough
at this stage companies are still hiring
and Manufacturing activity is ongoing
and margins of companies also start to
increase
then we reach the peak the peak is the
highest point of economic activity in
the business cycle at this stage growth
begins to slow and even starts to
decrease
and the economy reaches a state of
Maximum output however signs of
potential inflationary pressures May
begin to emerge at this point fiscal and
monetary policies employed by the
central banks and governments may go in
the opposite direction to prevent too
much growth which is inflation
additionally economic growth stagnates
and employers have trouble finding
workers and wages increase in value this
is an effective inflation
additionally earnings start to
disappoint workers against high
expectations due to economic growth
this leads into a recession or a
contraction
so following the peak the enemy the
economy enters this contractionary phase
economic indicators like GDP employment
and consumer spending which we touched
upon earlier start to decline businesses
cut down on production start laying off
employees and this may result in a
decrease in consumer conflicts this
phase is commonly referred to as a
recession however but it can this trade
varies depending on the severity and
duration of this period
business cycle is driven by various
factors including shifts in consumer and
investor sentiments increased technology
and changes to monitoring fiscal
policies however it is continuous and it
always happens however one thing to note
is that in this graph we see the
business cycle as reaching the trough
again right
but one thing to notice is that the
economy is constantly growing so it's on
an upward Trend however these Cycles go
throughout the upward track
if that makes sense if you look closely
here the trough in the original early
cycle is a bit lower than the trough
after we reach the recession this shows
that the economy is growing however
while it's growing it is experiencing
Cycles
okay so the key factors of the macro
economy that we'll be touching upon GDP
or gross domestic product on employment
slash unemployment inflation and
interest rates which we've already
discussed
so first what is GDP GDP or the gross
domestic product of a company represents
the total cost of goods being sold in
that country or in that nation in a
period typically one year so GDP is
calculated as consumer spending which is
C Investments made which is I government
spending which is G and the difference
between exports and imports which is
represented as x minus m
okay something to note between about
Industries and the business Cycles
certain industries and companies are
divided into categories called cyclical
or defensive categories
cyclical Industries are Industries which
face the repercussions of the business
cycle during certain times they will be
in an upward boom and during certain
times they may not be able to operate at
all
examples of this include the hotel
industry Resorts dining and any other
excessive industries that are created by
consumer wants
defensive Industries on the other hand
are things that aren't too heavily
affected by the business cycle this is
because they're necessary for human
operation things like this include
Health Services utilities Health
technology and so on
however some Industries are in between
cyclical and defensive for example
consumer services are somewhat cyclical
and somewhat defensive
for example things like accommodation
are cyclical and defensive to some
extent
some houses in certain areas which maybe
seem as seen as luxury may be cyclical
when it comes to renting or on Airbnb
however basic accommodation is defensive
since humans need it at all times
so first unemployment so unemployment is
splitted to three categories cyclical
structural and frictional
so what is cyclical unemployment
cyclical unemployment results from
fluctuations in the overall economy when
the economy enters a recession or a
downturn demand for goods and services
decreases causing businesses to scale
back production as a result they lay off
workers leading to cyclical unemployment
consider the construction industry
during an economic boom there's a high
demand for new homes and infrastructural
projects construction companies hire
more workers to meet this growing demand
however when a recession hits the demand
for new projects drops causing these
companies to cut back on their Workforce
resulting in cyclical unemployment for
construction workers
similarly in the tourism sector when the
economy is thriving people have more
disposable income to travel and explore
this leads to increased demand for
flights hotels entertainment like movies
and so on yet in an economic downturn
people tighten their budgets leading to
reduced travel and low demand for these
tourism related services and as a result
there are losses in jobs in this
industry in both examples cyclical
unemployment is closely tied to the
fluctuations in the business cycle which
we saw earlier as the economy contracts
and expands industries that heavily rely
on consumer spending and Investments can
experience shifts in employment levels
due to the changes in demand
next we have structural unemployment
structural unemployment arises from a
mismatch between the skills and
qualifications of job Seekers and the
requirements of available jobs this
mismatch is often caused by changes in
the economy such as due to technology or
shifts in consumer preferences making
certain skills obsolete or less in
demand for instance let's consider the
decline of a typewriter industry with
the Advent of computers skilled typists
who were very proficient at using a
typewriter might have found themselves
structurally unemployed as the demand
for their specific skill set efficient
use of the typewriter dwindled due to
technological advancements this is
because computers were much more
efficient much more accessible and
people could do the same job that
typewriters could do at home by
themselves
another example could be seen in the
decline of manufacturing jobs in certain
regions as manufacturing processes
became more automated companies may
require fewer workers on the factory
floor
this can lead to structural unemployment
as individuals with specific skills to
manual assembly or machine operations
face challenges of finding relevant
employment
in the modern context rapid advancements
in artificial intelligence and
automation could potentially lead to
structural employment for certain
administrative roles which do work that
AI can easily replace
these include tasks like data entry or
customer service which AI even at its
current state can likely handle
rendering these traditional jobs
unnecessary
structural unemployment underscores the
importance of continuous skill
development and add that patient to
changing job markets individuals need to
retain and acquire new skills to remain
competitive in an evolving landscape and
minimize the impact of structural shifts
in the economy
lastly we have frictional unemployment
frictional unemployment is likely the
type of unemployment that most people
will experience it occurs when
individuals are transitioning between
jobs or entering the workforce for the
first time
it's a natural and unavoidable aspect of
a dynamic job market where people are
constantly seeking better higher paying
jobs with better benefits while employer
employers are looking for better and
better candidates
imagine a recent college graduate
entering the job market they might
experience frictional unemployment as
they search for their first full-time
position during this time they're
looking for a job that aligns with their
skills interests career goals pay and
maybe it's even close to their house
this process of searching and applying
and interviewing and negotiating tasks
takes time and can result in temporary
unemployment which we refer to as
frictional on a plan
another example is when someone
voluntarily leaves a job to pursue a new
opportunity they may experience ritual
unemployment during the gap between
leaving one job and starting their next
job this Gap is often necessary to
handle the logistics of transitioning
such as relocating or completing
necessary paperwork
frictional unemployment while inevitable
can be reduced through effective job
search strategies networking and the use
of online job job platforms
it's important to note that frictional
unemployment is generally considered to
be a healthy aspect of the of a dynamic
job market as it reflects the
individual's ability to move and their
flexibility in pursuing opportunities
that best fit their skill sets and
aspirations
so
inflation when we're calculating GDP as
we learned earlier the value of money
changes over time money in the future is
not worth the same as it is right not as
a result GDP numbers without being
deflated could show consistent growth
whereas in reality the real GDP which is
what we refer to GDP with the time value
of money taken into account could be
decreasing as a result to calculate the
real GDP of a country we'll take the
nominal GDP which is what would be
reported and we take away the impact of
inflation
okay so who is really playing a role in
the macro economy so the two main
players that control it are the
governments and central banks which
Implement and develop policies
and as a result companies and consumers
are impacted by these changes and need
to react
so governments Implement fiscal policy
whereas Banks Implement monetary policy
so first what is monetary policy
monetary policy involves A bank's
management of a country's money supply
and interest rates to influence economic
activity by adjusting interest rates and
employing tools like open market
operations central banks can control
inflation encourage borrowing and
spending during slow economic periods
using expansionary monetary policy or
cooldown and overheating economy using a
contractionary monetary policy
expansionary monetary policy is when
central banks reduce interest rates to
make borrowing money easier for
consumers this is because the interest
they would have to pay on a loan reduces
making taking a loan much more appealing
contractionary monetary policy on the
other hand is when central banks
increase interest rates to make
borrowing more expensive causing uh
borrowers to pay more interest on their
loans decreasing the appeal of these
loans
an interesting example of monetary
policy in action is Japan's use of
interest rates to stimulate the economy
typically any country that is using
expansionary monetary policy interest
rates could be lowered from three
percent to two percent for example to
encourage borrowing Japan however
decided to take an unconventional
approach the bank of Japan set an
interest rate of negative 0.1 this is
extremely unique and a choice made by
Japan's government to meet their
specific needs
this was their attempt to overcome
deflation which was a big issue in Japan
by making interest rates negative it
makes it more economical to borrow and
spend money than just holding on to it
as a result people kept taking on loans
because it was generating that money and
as a result they started spending more
which stimulated Japan's economy and it
has bored fruit for the country of Japan
now fiscal policy fiscal policy it
involves how governments use taxes and
spending to influence the country's
caught
by adjusting tax rates and government
spending levels governments aim to
stimulate the economic growth during
downturns using expansionary fiscal
policy or control inflation during
periods of high growth using contract
sharing fiscal policy so expansionary
fiscal policy similar to expansionary
monetary policy is when governments
spend more money to increase the
circulation of money within the circular
flow of income which creates jobs and
more contractually fiscal policy is when
governments increase interest rates to
decrease the disposable income of people
to reduce their spendings
an example of how governments can spend
their money is through investment in
military Investments and infrastructure
or investments in social program which
stimulate the economy and can be called
injections
the ways they can influence tax rates
are through increases or decreases in
corporate tax and increases or decreases
in individual attacks like income rates
fiscal policy as we mentioned earlier
can be expansionary to promote spending
or contractually to reduce spending
as you can assume monetary policy which
is influenced by the central bank is
much more fast acting than fiscal policy
controlling interest rates is much
faster than starting infrastructural
projects which can take years to see the
effects of
because interest rates can directly
affect money circulation they affect
much faster whereas things like
infrastructural projects their benefits
come from increased employment and
injections into the economy in the form
of available buildings where companies
can relocate this often takes time for
companies to find these locations to
relocate and additionally employment
doesn't immediately increase uh the
economy
in this section we'll be going over ESG
or environment social and governance for
short
ESG has become a topic of much concern
in recent years especially but has
existed for hundreds of years and even
beyond that ESG is the social mission of
a company and integrating social aspects
and objectives within the company's
goals
however there is an increasing demand
for ESG in the investing process from
investors and stakeholders alike however
there is so much skepticism regarding
the role of ESG and responsible
investing and the idea that focusing on
ESG means compromising returns however
this isn't the case in this section
we'll be going over what ESG is why it's
so important and how investors should
take into consideration ESG not only
Advanced social goals but to ensure that
their portfolios are profitable
all right so first what is ESG ESG which
stands for environmental social and
governments is a comprehensive framework
that evaluates a company's performance
and practices in three key areas the
environmental aspect focuses on how a
company interacts with the planet from
how it goes about carbon emissions to
managing resources to addressing waste
waste and pollution the social aspect
revolves around relationships including
how a company treats its employees
Fosters diversity and inclusion and
engage in and engages with local
communities through initiatives and
philanthropy ncsr finally the governance
aspect examines the company's internal
structure ethics and accountability this
encompasses everything from the
composition of the board of directors to
ensuring transparency integrity and
adherence to regulations
ESG is more than just a trend it's a
strategic approach that considers the
broader impact of business activities on
the environment society and ethical
practices
so the origin of ESG although ESG has
become much more well known with people
outside the investing landscape in
recent years it's existed for so long
the origins of ESG can be traced back to
the mid 20th century when discussions
about Corporate social responsibility
started to take shape however it wasn't
until the 1960s and 70s fueled by social
movements advocating for civil rights
that awareness of corporate impacts
began to grow this era saw the emergence
of ethical investing where investors
excluded industries that conflicted with
their own moral values Global crises
including environmental disasters and
financial meltdowns further highlighted
the urgent need for responsible business
practices
in 2006 the United Nations took a
significant step by launching the
principles for responsible investment or
PRI for short signaling a formal
commitment to integrating ESG
considerations into investment decisions
today these historical Milestones
collectively paved the way for
development and widespread adoption of
ESG framework that we recognize today
okay so the importance of ESG the
significance of ESG lies in its ability
to guide businesses towards long-term
sustainability and success by
integrating environmental social and
governance factors companies not only
reduce their environmental footprint
companies not only reduce their
environmental footprint but also Foster
Innovation and adapt to changing
Landscapes ESG practices aren't just
about doing good they're about managing
risks effectively identifying potential
environmental and social vulnerabilities
can Shield a company from future
disruptions moreover a robust ESG
strategy enhances a company's reputation
building credibility and trust with
stakeholders this is especially crucial
in an era where consumers and investors
expect more than just Financial returns
Beyond yes Beyond reputation ESG
practices ensure Regulatory Compliance
as standards evolve demonstrating a
commitment to ethical conduct and
transparency
in essence ESG is more than just a
buzzword it's a strategic imperative
that not only ensures businesses Thrive
but also contribute positively to the
world around them
so let's look at it in the modern
investing lens ESG has transformed the
investment landscape by introducing a
responsible approach to decision making
investors now Factor ESU considerations
when crafting their portfolios and align
their Investments with ethical and
sustainable values
it's not just about these values though
it's about potential Financial benefits
ESG integration offers the promise of
improved risk adjusted returns as
companies with strong ESU practices
often demonstrate resilience when faced
with uncertainty ESG aligned companies
also appeal to investors with a
long-term Outlook as they prioritize
sustainability in both environmental and
self-sustainability and are better
equipped to weather Market fluctuations
notability notably Research indicates
that companies excelling an ESG perform
a performance can even outperform their
peers financially Beyond profit ESG
opens doors to impact investing where
investors actively contribute to
positive societal and environmental
changes through their investment choices
the integration of ESG factors signal a
fundamental shift in how investors
perceive value emphasizing both
Financial returns and contributions to a
more sustainable world
so this is especially important in a
modern world with factors like social
media ESG has become even more important
and companies that fail to adopt ESG are
placed under much more scrutiny as we'll
see in future examples compared to
companies who do adopt ESG
so the impacts on stakeholders ESG
doesn't just affect the company's
internal practices it extends to his
relationship with stakeholders employees
for instance are more engaged and
satisfied when they work for a company
that prioritizes their well-being and
supports a positive workplace culture
through ESG practices customers too are
brought are drawn to brands that align
with their own values and ESG provides
that connection companies with strong
ESG values tend to attract and retain
socially conscious customers thus
strengthening brand loyalty Beyond
employees and customers ESG initiatives
have a positive ripple effect on their
local communities contributing to
societal well-being and forging deeper
Community connections investors and
other stakeholders also expect
transparency and ethical conduct making
ESG an essential aspect of building
Trust
ultimately effective ESG practices
manage not only a company's reputation
but also its relationship with the
broader ecosystem that it operates
Within
the global impact of ESG
as we said before ESG is not limited to
companies and not just communities
either and it has a significant effect
on Global Outreach by prioritizing
environmental sustainability ESG
practices align with global objectives
such as mitigating climate change and
conserving biodiversity on the social
front ESG initiatives address pressing
challenges like poverty and inequality
contributing to a broader Global
development the collaborative nature of
ESG becomes evident through Partnerships
between companies governments and
organizations across borders all working
together to address shared challenges
ESG encourages companies to innovate
sustainable sustainably develop
solutions that can drive positive
impacts on a global scale and innovate
more
so as a financial investor how do you
assess a business's ESG now that we've
established that ESG is important how do
we go about measuring it
assessing accompanies ESG performance
involves evaluating its practices across
environmental social and governance
dimensions
ESG rating agencies play a pivotal role
providing scores based on established
criteria that measure companies
alignment with ESG practices
in some sectors specific ESG standards
are in place setting expectations for
how companies should operate
sustainability sustainably as you can
see on screen there's something called
the msci ESG rate which is one of the
ESG rating agencies
additionally transparency is key as
companies share their ESG data through
reports disclosing their efforts and
impacts a critical aspect is materiality
which means focusing on the ESG factors
most relevant to account being as
industry this ensures that efforts are
targeted where they matter most ESG
assessments serve as a dynamic tool for
companies not just to measure their
current performance but to identify
areas for growth and enhancement
so how can businesses incorporate ESG
incorporating ESG into business
operations requires a nuanced and
comprehensive approach it starts with
strong leadership commitment with top
management actively championing ESG
principles it can't just be an
afterthought it needs to be integrated
into the core business strategy along
with the business principles and the
business plan which we discussed earlier
stakeholder engagement is critical
involving employees customers and
partners ensures that ESG initiatives
align with their needs and concerns to
measure progress establish clear ESG
metrics and targets or maybe consult ESG
agencies this helps hold companies
accountable for their efforts
additionally awareness is key so
employees understand the significance of
ESG and their role and its
implementation
Innovation thrives when ESG goals are
aligned so companies should encourage
research and development that supports
sustainability
so ESG versus non-exg stocks although
we've clearly established that ESG does
have benefits how does it really help in
reality Theory isn't always right
so let's look at in reality the choice
between ESG and non-esg stocks has had
significant implications for investors
ESG align companies tend to demonstrate
better risk management and resilience
against Market turbulence as we
mentioned earlier
Research indicates that over the long
term ESG stocks could potentially
outperform their non-esg counterparts
driven by sustainable practices and
responsible strategies moreover as the
demand for ethical and sustainable
Investments grow especially in the
modern world ESG stocks could experience
increased investor interest the ESG
allian companies may also face fewer
regulatory hurdles and reputational
risks making them more potentially
stable choices for example they may not
be affected by laws governing carbon
taxes and they may not have fit quotas
which most companies that are not ESU
focused may fail to meet
Beyond just Financial gains investing in
ESG stocks also aligns with broader
Trends in responsible investing and
sustainable consumer Behavior
so let's look at a mock situation and
compare two companies one which follows
ESG practices and one that doesn't
a company that uses renewable produces
renewable energy has a stop a strong
track record of reducing carbon
emissions and promoting clear energy as
a result they've experienced steady
growth driven by an increased demand for
Renewable Energy Products and renewable
energy resources and favorable
regulatory policies which may reduce tax
or provide subsidies additionally
they'll experience positive media which
can also help boost the company on the
other hand a company which relies on
fossil fuels will experience criticism
for their environmental impact and
negative media due to their
contributions to climate change as a
result their stock is likely to be
volatile due to fluctuating oil prices
in a dynamic Market changing that market
dynamics and growing concerns about
environmental sustainability as a result
in this situation it's clear that the
prior case is better when they use
renewable energy
additionally let's look at a second
example but this time focusing on the
social and governance aspects
any diverse workplace a company that
promotes a gender and ethnic diversity
and a Workforce that that represents a
wide range of backgrounds is more likely
to succeed than one that doesn't have
these same practices this is because
employees are likely to be more
motivated in the workplace and media is
likely to show companies that focus on
diversity in a positive light whereas
companies that don't Focus are likely to
face criticism
however this is a nuanced approach we
need to look at reality and in some
cases companies that don't have ESG
principles in the moment may outperform
those which do however in the long run
it's important to note that as the world
becomes increasingly focused on social
objectives ESG will grow in importance
and as a result
non-esg companies that made beef in a
better position now may not be in that
same position in the future
so in this section we'll just go over
how to construct a portfolio and
diversification and the types of
management and the basics of how you
construct a portfolio so first of all
what is diversification diversification
is essentially the process of purchasing
assets from a different type of uh from
different asset classes to expand the
number and type of Securities in your
portfolio
so if we look at this diagram we can see
here that on the x-axis there's a number
of Securities and on the num on the
y-axis there's a standard deviation of
your portfolio's return
the height represents the total risk and
as you can see as the number of
Securities in your portfolio increases
the number the amount of unsystematic
risk decreases where systematic risk
persists and we'll get to that in a bit
essentially by purchasing more
Securities you're putting your your
going with the concept of not putting
all your eggs in one basket and since
you're spreading your risk over the
portfolio by choosing companies in
different sectors and industries you're
able to avoid
your portfolio crashing if one of these
things fails
empirical evidence suggests that all it
takes is about 30 to 40 different
Securities to achieve a fully
Diversified portfolio
okay so what are the types of risk well
they're systematic and unsystematic risk
systematic risk is a market risk which
is non-diversible which means you can
get rid of it if you diversify and it
stems from market-wide risks
unsystematic risks on the other hand are
company or industry specific risks that
are inherent to a specific investment
systematic risks are non-diversifiable
which means they cannot be get that they
cannot be get rid of
this is a risk that remains after
efforts have been taken to diversify a
portfolio systematic risk incorporates
things like interest rate changes
inflation recessions and Wars among
other major changes shifts in these
things can affect the entire market and
cannot be mitigated by changing
positions within a portfolio of equities
because it affects every single equity
for example the global financial crisis
is a great example of systematic risk
anyone who invested in the market in
2008 saw the values of their investment
changed drastically from this economic
event the Great Recession affected asset
classes in different ways as riskier
Securities typically those that were
leveraged more were sold off in large
quantities whereas simpler assets like
treasury bonds became more valuable
unsystematic risk is a company or
industry-specific risk that is inherent
with each investment and other somatic
risks can be reduced by diversifying as
we've seen in this diagram
systematic risks include things like
inflation risk interest rate risk
exchange rate risk and things like
pandemics and War unsystematic risks are
things like business risk Financial Risk
default risk and liquidity risk which
are specific to certain companies
so how do you measure your portfolio's
performance
well the best way to do so is using
benchmarks
a benchmark is a standard tool or
measure that you can use to analyze the
risk of a gear and portfolio individual
and funds individual funds and
investment portfolios will typically
have an established Benchmark that you
can already use for standard analysis to
check your level of risk
okay time weighted versus dollar
weighted returns
Time Warner returns are determined
without regard to any subsequent cash
flows from the investor it measures the
performance of the investment over a
certain period of time not the returns
of the investor returns quoted by mutual
funds and other investment managers are
time weighted because the portfolio
manager doesn't have any control over
future cash flows of investor dollars in
contrast a dollar weighted return
considers subsequent contributions to
and withdrawals from an investment for
example it considers timings and sales
of purchases
a dollar weighted approach focuses on
the returns of the investor over a
period of time and this will usually
differ from the time weighted return
so how do you measure portfolio risk
well to measure risk we need to identify
what risk is as we mentioned earlier
risk is the chance that a stock might
fail or the risk of volatility
so to measure risk we would measure the
chance that the performance of your
portfolio as a whole would differ from
the returns of the market or The
Benchmark portfolio
and the best way to calculate risk is
using a standard deviation which gives
you returns over a given period standard
deviation is the measure of dispersion
of a set of data from its meat it
measures the absolute variability of a
distribution
in essence the greater the standard
deviation the greater the the deviation
from the mean
and this is the formula to calculate
standard deviation if any of you have
taken statistics before you'd be able to
understand it but if not it's not
necessary that you understand how to
calculate standard deviation to actually
employ it you can use any online
calculator to actually figure it out
so here is a standard deviation belt
curve essentially the areas within the
curves are more are the higher likely
opportunities so in this general area
68.27 of
opportunities will boil best but as we
go to the extremes more and more
situations will fall under the blanket
however the rate at which it does so is
diminishing
so active versus passive management
passive investment strategies seek to
replicate replicate the constituents
weights and therefore the risks and
returns of a specific benchmark of index
Securities it's a Buy and Hold strategy
that does not seek to pick winners and
losers among the Securities but rather
just hold them and see how things play
out the benefits of passive management
include low fees enhanced tax efficiency
that stems from low portfolio turnover
and a limited portfolio management
infrastructure essentially meaning it's
easier to manage yourself the most
popular use vehicles for pasta
investment I include indexed mutual
funds and ETFs or exchange traded funds
active management on the other hand is
based on the belief that risk adjusted
returns above the Benchmark can be
achieved through security selection
Market timing and sector rotations by
highly skilled professional portfolio
managers essentially meaning you pick
and choose stocks based on how you think
they're going to do actively managed
portfolios generally result in
significant portfolio turnover as the
manager reacts to Market and temporary
Trends either observed or forecasted
this High turnover combined with the
costs to staff our portfolio and
management team requires a manager to
charge significantly higher fees than
they would charge for a passively
managed portfolio and generally
generally results in poor tax efficiency
as frequent buying and selling of
Securities may result in something
called a capital gains tax which is
which is essentially the tax you pay
when you sell stocks this capital gains
tax is greater when you sell a stock
within a period of less than a year and
it's less when you sell a stock that
you've held for a greater than a year
in the past the S P 500 has had
significantly more success than actively
traded uh portfolios this has been
occurring for the past 20 years and you
could replicate the index yourself
for example you can buy all 500 stocks
in the S P 500 in the same proportion
that they are in the S P 500 index
but the issue with that is that you
would have to constantly monitor the
Investments and buy and sell at the
weights of these companies on the index
some large institutional investors like
Pension funds do this but it's more
impractical for day-to-day investors
like you and me
especially when you look at just the S P
500 when you look at things like the
Russell 2000 it becomes even more
impractical
for us there are two options index
mutual funds and index ETFs which are
similar to mutual funds but trade
continuously over the course of a day
like a stock
but in reality it's not best to stick to
either passive or active investment but
rather to do a hybrid form of management
where you incorporate both aspects some
index and some active stocks
let's look at Gail Yale with their fixed
income had an internal team to buy
Securities and bought a number of fixed
assets and active assets to generate
revenues
if you've looked at the news recently or
in the past you may have seen how active
managers are outpacing things like the S
P 500 for example Peter Lynch racked up
a 29 return at Magnum fund from 1977 to
1990 including dividends and he outpaced
the S P 500 by more than 13 a year
during that time
however his investing style was very
lucrative during that period And
although some people may have praised
him we can introduce that to some extent
luck was an important factor in his
success although he did buy high quality
companies that traded at a reasonable
price he wasn't able to do this for a
consistent period of time
unlike what you would be able to do with
investing in S P 500 for a longer period
of time
so although certain stock Pickers are
able to beat funds like the S P 500 it's
a mistake to assume that this success
will persist into the future
as a result it's important to diversify
your portfolio by also including stocks
that are passive that you don't need to
manage as much and active funds as well
now in this short section after we've
discussed all these financial
investments I want to talk to you about
alternative Investments throughout this
course we've talked about stocks bonds
business strategy the economy financial
documents and so on but there's so many
different ways of investing beyond the
traditional stocks and bonds that many
people are already limited to think are
the only viable investment opportunities
as you will go about investing as a
business person and as an individual
you'll come by opportunities to invest
in non-conventional Investments
examples of these include real estate
equipment leasing hedge funds and in
recent years things like
cryptocurrencies and nfts it's important
to realize these are viable investment
opportunities although they aren't as
commonly used as stocks and bonds
although some can argue they are they
are alternative Investments that can
generate yields and profits if invested
in appropriately
so this section is just to talk to you a
little bit about what are these
alternative Investments and some of the
characteristics of these alternative
Investments
so we've had the general Investments
like Equity private equity and things
like Venture Capital private Equity
being sure as you've bought in a company
and Venture Capital being Capital raised
from Venture capitalists who are people
who are wealthy enough to invest in
companies but alternative Investments
like real estate include purchasing land
or purchasing property equipment leasing
can be when you a lot when you well
lease equipment as a business which can
help you generate Revenue when you
aren't using equipment hedge funds which
are a little bit more complicated but
they're similar to investing in a group
of stocks Commodities or precious metals
yes you can invest in things like
lithium or aluminum
cryptocurrencies and collectibles so
things like Bitcoin ethereum and so on
and nfds
so what are some of the characteristics
of these alternative Investments well if
you look at real estate for example
they're not very liquid so illiquidity
which does increase risk however this
varies from investment to investment
additionally uh they are sold by
financial advisors or broker dealers
mostly to accredited investors as a
result they aren't as easy to come by or
as easy to invest in like stocks and
bonds are
additionally they're to either public or
private assets but they're rarely
publicly traded like stocks are on the
stock market
um
yeah something to note is that these
Investments are high risk High reward
so it they are likely to Skyrocket in
price like we've seen with the
cryptocurrency Rises but they're also
likely to fall
and cause you to lose a lot of money so
when you're investing in alternative
Investments especially those with which
you're not very well versed make sure
you make an informed decision and go
about investing in a safe and ethical
way so you don't miss out
all right everyone that's a wrap on this
course and just to summarize we'll go
through everything that we've learned so
we've learned about the time value of
money how a mortgage can rack up
compound interest things like how to
identify if an investment's a good
investment the importance of capital
markets at ESG all relevant in business
we've also learned things like the
business cycle fiscal and monetary
policy and looked at case studies like
Japan to understand the basics of
economics
for finance we've looked at the various
financial documents how to diversify
your portfolio how to mitigate risk and
things and the basics of Statistics
throughout this course you realize that
all of these three disciplines are
highly interconnected and you can study
one without understanding the basics of
some of the others
I'd like to say congratulations to all
of you who have made it this far and
this knowledge will serve you well as
you go into the future and explore these
Concepts in further depth
I'd like to remind you one more time
that I do have a YouTube channel called
change makers media which you'll see in
the comments section I post videos on
teenagers who are making an impact in
their local and international
communities I would greatly appreciate
it if you guys could go down there and
subscribe to show your support for these
teenagers and encourage these change
makers to continue impacting the world
that's it for me everybody thank you so
much I'll see you in the future bye-bye